se transformaba en una enfermedad curable o tratable.
Si uno tiene una neumonía,
toma penicilina,
se mata el microbio
y cura la enfermedad.
Era tan seductora esta idea,
de la metáfora potente de bloquear y cerrar
y matar algo,
que realmente se extendió en la biología.
Fue una transformación como ninguna otra.
Y realmente hemos pasado los últimos 100 años
tratando de replicar ese modelo una y otra vez
con enfermedades no infecciosas,
en enfermedades crónicas como diabetes, hipertensión y enfermedades del corazón.
Y ha funcionado, pero solo en parte.
Dejen que lo explique.
Si se toma todo el universo
de las reacciones químicas en el cuerpo humano,
todas las reacciones químicas que el cuerpo puede hacer,
la mayoría de la gente piensa que esa cifra es de un millón.
Digamos que es un millón.
Y ahora uno se hace la pregunta,
¿qué número o fracción de reacciones
en realidad son objetivo
de la farmacopea, de toda la química medicinal?
Ese número es 250.
El resto es oscuridad química.
En otras palabras, el 0,025 % de todas las reacciones químicas del cuerpo
son en realidad objeto del mecanismo de bloquear y cerrar.
Si se piensa en la fisiología humana
como una vasta red telefónica mundial
que interactúa con nodos y piezas,
entonces toda nuestra química médica
opera en un pequeño rincón
en el borde, el borde exterior, de esa red.
Es como si toda nuestra química farmacéutica
fuese un operador de la pole en Wichita, Kansas
que manipula entre 10 y 15 líneas telefónicas.
Entonces, ¿qué hacemos con esta idea?
¿Qué pasa si reorganizamos este enfoque?
De hecho, resulta que el mundo natural
nos da una idea de cómo se podría pensar la enfermedad
de manera radicalmente diferente,
en lugar de enfermedad, fármaco y blanco.
De hecho, el mundo natural está organizado jerárquicamente
hacia arriba, no hacia abajo.
Se comienza con una unidad semiautónoma y autorregulada llamada célula.
Estas unidades semiautónomas y autorreguladas
dan lugar a las unidades semiautónomas y autorreguladas llamadas órganos,
y estos órganos se unen para formar los llamados seres humanos,
y estos organismos en última instancia, viven en entornos
que son en parte semiautónomos y en parte autorregulados.
Lo bueno de este sistema, este esquema jerárquico,
es que se construye hacia arriba y no hacia abajo,
lo que nos permite pensar en la enfermedad
de una manera diferente.
Pongamos una enfermedad como el cáncer.
Desde la década de 1950,
se ha intentado desesperadamente aplicar al cáncer el modelo de bloqueo y cierre.
Hemos tratado de eliminar las células
usando una variedad de quimioterapias o terapias dirigidas,
y como muchos sabemos, ha funcionado.
Ha funcionado para enfermedades como la leucemia;
para algunos tipos de cáncer de mama,
pero con el tiempo ese enfoque toca techo.
Y en los últimos 10 años más o menos
hemos empezado a pensar en usar el sistema inmunológico,
recordando que la célula cancerosa no crece en el vacío.
En realidad, crece en un organismo humano.
Y ¿se podría utilizar la capacidad del organismo,
el sistema inmune que tienen los humanos, para atacar el cáncer?
Esto ha conllevado a nuevos y espectaculares fármacos contra el cáncer.
Y por último está el nivel del medio ambiente, ¿no?
No pensamos en el cáncer como la alteración del medio ambiente.
Pero daré un ejemplo de un entorno profundamente cancerígeno.
Se llama prisión.
Pongan soledad, depresión, confinamiento,
y a eso agreguen
enrollado en una hojita de papel blanco,
uno de los neuroestimulantes conocidos más potentes, la nicotina,
y se agrega una de las sustancias adictivas más potentes que ya saben,
y se obtiene un entorno procancerígeno.
Pero se pueden tener ambientes anticancerígenos también.
Hay intentos de crear ambientes,
cambiar p. ej. el medio hormonal para el cáncer de mama.
Intentamos cambiar el medio metabólico para otras formas de cáncer.
O tomar otra enfermedad, como la depresión.
Una vez más, trabajando hacia arriba,
desde los años 1960 y 1970, de nuevo, hemos intentado, desesperadamente
apagar las moléculas que operan entre las células nerviosas,
la serotonina, la dopamina,
y tratamos de curar la depresión de esa manera,
y funcionó, pero luego se alcanza el límite.
Y ahora sabemos que lo que realmente se debe hacer
es cambiar la fisiología del órgano, el cerebro,
recablearlo, remodelarla,
y que, por supuesto, se ha demostrado estudio tras estudio
que la terapia conversacional hace exactamente eso,
estudio tras estudio ha demostrado que la terapia conversacional
combinada con medicamentos, pastillas,
es mucho más eficaz que cualquiera de ellos solo.
¿Es imaginable un entorno más inmersivo para cambiar la depresión?
¿Se pueden bloquear las señales que provoca la depresión?
Una vez más, moviéndonos hacia arriba en esta cadena jerárquica organizativa.
De lo que realmente se trata aquí
no es del medicamento en sí, sino de una metáfora.
En lugar de matar algo,
en el caso de las enfermedades degenerativas crónicas como
insuficiencia renal, diabetes, hipertensión, artrosis...
tal vez lo que hay que hacer es cambiar la metáfora para que crezca algo.
Y esa es la clave, quizás,
para replantearnos la forma de pensar la medicina.
Ahora bien, esta idea de cambiar,
de crear un cambio de percepción, por así decirlo,
llegó a mí de una manera muy personal hace unos 10 años.
Hace unos 10 años... he sido corredor la mayor parte de mi vida.
Iba a correr por la mañana del sábado,
Volví, me desperté y, básicamente, no podía moverme.
Tenía la rodilla derecha hinchada,
y se podía oír el crujido ominoso del hueso contra el hueso.
Y una de las ventajas de ser médico es pedir las propias resonancias magnéticas.
Y tenía una resonancia magnética la siguiente semana y era así.
Esencialmente, el menisco de cartílago de entre el hueso
estaba completamente roto y el hueso hecho añicos.
Ahora, si intentan sentir lástima por mí,
déjenme mencionar algunos hechos.
De hacer una resonancia magnética de cada uno de este público,
el 60 % mostrarían signos
de degeneración ósea y degeneración del cartílago como este.
el 85 % de todas las mujeres a la edad de 70
mostraría una degeneración de moderada a severa del cartílago.
Del 50 % al 60 % de los hombres en esta audiencia
también tendría tales signos.
Así que esta es una enfermedad muy común.
La segunda ventaja de ser médico
es que uno puede experimentar sus propias dolencias.
Así que hace unos 10 años que comenzamos,
llevamos este proceso al laboratorio,
y empezamos a hacer experimentos sencillos,
para mecánicamente intentar arreglar esta degeneración.
Tratamos de inyectar químicos en los espacios de la rodilla de los animales
para tratar de revertir la degeneración del cartílago,
y para abreviar el proceso muy largo y doloroso,
esencialmente se quedó en nada.
No pasó nada.
Y hace unos 7 años, tuvimos un doctorando de Australia.
Lo bueno de los australianos
es que están habituados a ver el mundo al revés.
(Risas)
Y así Dan me sugirió: "Tal vez no sea un problema mecánico.
Puede no ser un problema químico. Quizás sea un problema de células madre".
En otras palabras, tenía dos hipótesis.
Número uno, no existe algo como una célula madre del esqueleto,
una célula madre del esqueleto que reúna todo el esqueleto de los vertebrados,
hueso, cartílago y elementos fibrosos del esqueleto,
al igual que hay una célula madre en la sangre,
y al igual que hay una célula madre en el sistema nervioso.
Y dos, que en vez de eso, la degeneración o disfunción de esta célula madre
es lo que está causando la artritis osteocondral, una dolencia muy común.
Así que en realidad la pregunta fue, buscamos un fármaco,
realmente, cuando deberíamos buscar una célula.
Así que cambiamos nuestros modelos,
y empezamos a buscar células madre del esqueleto.
Y para acortar de nuevo la versión larga,
hace unos cinco años, encontramos estas células.
Ellas viven en el interior del esqueleto.
He aquí un esquema y una foto real de una de ellas.
La materia blanca es hueso,
y estas columnas rojas que se ven y las celdas amarillas
son células surgidas a partir de una célula madre única del esqueleto,
columnas de cartílago, columnas de hueso que sale de una sola célula.
Estas células son fascinantes. Tienen cuatro propiedades.
Número uno: viven donde se espera que vivan.
Viven justo debajo de la superficie del hueso,
bajo el cartílago.
La biología es ubicación, ubicación, ubicación.
Y se mueven en las áreas apropiadas y forman el hueso y el cartílago.
Esa es una.
Número dos, una propiedad interesante.
Se pueden extraer del esqueleto de los vertebrados,
pueden cultivarse en placas de Petri en el laboratorio,
y van muriendo para formar el cartílago.
¿Recuerden que no podíamos generar cartílago por amor o por dinero?
Estas células están muriendo para formar el cartílago.
Forman sus propios rollos de cartílago alrededor de sí mismos.
Número tres: también son
los talleres de reparación más eficaces de las fracturas que hemos detectado.
Este es un pequeño hueso, un hueso de ratón que fracturamos
y dejamos que se cure solo.
Estas células madre han entrado y reparado, en amarillo, el hueso,
en blanco, el cartílago, casi por completo.
Tanto es así que si se marca con un tinte fluorescente
se pueden ver como una especie de pegamento celular peculiar
que entra en la zona de una fractura,
la repara a nivel local y luego detiene su trabajo.
Número cuatro: La más ominosa,
y es que sus números disminuyen vertiginosamente,
precipitadamente, 10, 50 veces, a medida que envejece.
Y así lo que había sucedido, en realidad,
es que nos encontramos en un cambio de percepción.
Fuimos a la caza de los fármacos
pero terminamos encontrando teorías.
Y en cierto modo
nos habíamos enganchado de nuevo con esta idea:
células, organismos, ambientes,
porque estábamos ya pensando en las células madre de la médula,
estábamos pensando en la artritis como enfermedad celular.
Y la siguiente pregunta fue, ¿existen órganos?
¿Se puede construir esto como un órgano fuera del cuerpo?
¿Se puede implantar cartílago en las áreas de un trauma?
Y tal vez lo más interesante,
¿puede ascender y crear ambientes?
Sabemos que el ejercicio remodela los huesos,
pero, ninguno de nosotros hace ejercicio.
Así que ¿se podrían imaginar formas de carga y descarga pasiva del hueso
para que vuelva a crear o regenerar el cartílago degenerado?
Y tal vez más interesante, y más importante,
¿puede aplicarse este modelo más global fuera de la medicina?
Lo que está en juego no es matar algo,
sino hacer crecer algo.
Y esto plantea algunas de las preguntas más interesantes
acerca de cómo pensamos la medicina del futuro.
¿Podría su medicina ser una célula y no una píldora?
¿Cómo podemos cultivar estas células?
¿Qué podríamos hacer para detener el crecimiento maligno de estas células?
Hemos oído hablar de los problemas de desatar el crecimiento.
¿Podríamos implantar genes suicidas en estas células
para detener su crecimiento?
¿Podría ser su medicina un órgano que se crea fuera del cuerpo
y luego se implanta en el mismo?
¿Podría detener algo la degeneración?
¿Y si el órgano que se necesita es para tener memoria?
En casos de enfermedades del sistema nervioso
algunos de esos órganos tenían memoria.
¿Cómo podríamos reimplantar esos recuerdos?
¿Podríamos almacenar estos órganos?
¿Se debería desarrollar un órgano para cada ser humano
de forma individual y volverlo a colocar?
Y quizás lo más desconcertante,
¿podría ser su medicamento un medio ambiente?
¿Se podría patentar un medio ambiente?
Ya saben, en todas las culturas,
los chamanes han utilizado entornos como medicamentos.
¿Lo podríamos imaginar para nuestro futuro?
He hablado mucho sobre modelos. Comencé esta charla con modelos.
Así que terminaré con reflexiones sobre la construcción de modelos.
Eso es lo que hacemos como científicos.
Ya saben, cuando un arquitecto construye un modelo,
él o ella tratan de mostrar un mundo en miniatura.
Pero cuando un científico construye un modelo,
él o ella tratan de mostrar al mundo en metáfora.
Él o ella tratan de crear una nueva forma de ver.
El primero es un cambio de escala. Este último es un cambio de percepción.
Los antibióticos crean ese cambio perceptual
en cómo vemos la medicina, en realidad, teñida distorsionada,
con gran éxito, cómo se ha pensado la medicina durante los últimos cien años.
Pero necesitamos nuevos modelos para abordar la medicina en el futuro.
Eso es lo que está en juego.
Existe un tropo popular por ahí
de que la razón de no haber tenido el impacto transformador
en el tratamiento de las enfermedades
es por no haber tenido medicamentos lo suficientemente potentes.
Y eso es cierto en parte.
Pero tal vez la verdadera razón
es no tener suficientes formas poderosas de pensar los medicamentos.
Es cierto que
sería estupendo tener nuevos medicamentos.
Pero quizás lo que está realmente en juego son tres extremos intangibles:
mecanismos, modelos, metáforas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Me gusta mucho esta metáfora.
¿Cómo se enlaza?
Hay mucho que hablar en tecnologilandia
sobre la personalización de la medicina,
con todos estos datos y con los tratamientos médicos del futuro;
será para ti específicamente, el genoma, el contexto actual.
¿Es eso aplicable a este modelo tuyo?
Siddhartha Mukherjee: Es una pregunta muy interesante.
Hemos pensado sobre la personalización de la medicina
muy mucho en relación a la genómica.
Eso es porque el gen es una metáfora muy dominante,
una vez más, para utilizar la misma palabra, en la medicina actual,
que creemos que el genoma impulsará la personalización de la medicina.
Pero, por supuesto, el genoma es solo la parte inferior
de una larga cadena del ser, por así decirlo.
Esa cadena del ser, su primera unidad organizada es la célula.
Así que, si realmente abordamos la medicina de esta manera,
hay que pensar en la personalización de las terapias celulares,
y luego personalizar el órgano o las terapias del órgano,
y al final, la personalización de terapias de inmersión para el entorno.
Así que creo que en todas las etapas,
existe esa metáfora, hay tortugas hasta el final.
Bueno, en este, hay personalización en todo el trayecto.
CA: Así que cuando dices que la medicina podría ser una célula
y no una píldora,
estás hablando potencialmente de tus propias células.
SM: Por supuesto. CA: Convertidas en células madre,
tal vez probadas contra todo tipo de fármacos y preparados.
SM: Y quizá no exista. Esto es lo que estamos haciendo.
Esto es lo que está pasando, y nos movemos lentamente,
no lejos de la genómica, sino incorporando la genómica
en lo que llamamos multiorden,
los sistemas semiautónomos y autorregulados,
como las células, como los órganos, como los entornos.
CA: Muchas gracias.
SM: Un placer. Gracias.